ELISSA SHEVINSKY: Well, thank
you, [INAUDIBLE] for having me.
Thank you, Google,
for having me.
Thank you for coming.
"Lean Out," as I said,
our official pub date
is September 3.
So this is really
getting an early start.
And I think it's kind
of rad that Google
had me here considering
what the book is about.
So I've called this conversation
"Lean Out, Google, Lean Out!"
And here's my information.
I'm extremely friendly, as Josh
and [INAUDIBLE] can attest to.
They've known me since college.
And now you know me.
So feel free to stay in
touch with me on Twitter.
And this is a little about me.
I'm the editor of
this book "Lean Out."
And I'm also organizing
a security conference
in New York.
And I run a privacy company.
If you decide you
want more books,
they're on OrBooks or Amazon
or just yell at me on Twitter.
So it's pretty rad that
you invited me here today
considering what
this book is about.
I told a friend that I was
invited and he said, well,
they haven't read your book--
[LAUGHS]-- implying, of course,
if you knew what I was doing,
you would not have me here.
But I actually think
that's not true.
I think it's a reflection
of what Google's about that
you're welcoming me in to
have this conversation.
So one of the chapters in
this book is Erica Joy.
She published this
first on Medium
and agreed to let
us republish it,
which I was very grateful for.
It's called "The Other
Side of Diversity,"
and it's about,
among other things,
her negative experiences
as a black woman at Google.
So that's real.
That's a thing that happens.
But I'm optimistic
about Google, or shall
say Alphabet Inc.?
[LAUGHING] I see
a facepalm in the front row.
[LAUGHING]
I'm all for it.
I mean, this way they can
spin things out and avoid
lawsuits between divisions.
It's smart.
I was at the Lesbians Who Tech
event, and I saw Megan Smith.
And I just became such a
fan girl, not only for Smith
but for Google's efforts towards
gender inclusion and people
of color.
Megan Smith is saying
here in this GIF
the importance of diversity,
that the problems we
face as humanity-- I mean
she's thinking really big.
But they're so big that we
need to activate everyone.
We need everyone involved,
because how else are we
going to solve the
world's deepest problems?
And here she was at
the helm at Google.
And she spoke at
the Lesbians Who
Tech event about
the efforts Google
had made to attract
and hire women.
And I believe that
she was very sincere.
So I know that within Google,
these efforts have been made
and that they're real.
And so I come here today all
friendly-like, not hostile.
Despite what's in
this book, I fully
appreciate that Google
is a really big company
and that you've brought in some
of the best thinkers on this
and that there are people
here who are trying hard.
And so that's the spirit that I
want to have this conversation
today, that we're all here.
We want to make this better.
We're going to
acknowledge what's wrong
and also acknowledge that Google
has a lot of potential to be
part of making things better.
So to start, first,
a lot of feminists
have me blocked on Twitter.
So I may be kind of a
surprising person for you today.
And I have doubts
about the efforts
to recruit women and
underrepresented groups.
That's because women, LGBTQ, and
people of color in my network
are struggling to be
funded and promoted
and report sometimes
shocking harassment.
So I worry about
bringing in new people
before we figured out
how to retain and advance
the people who are here.
At the same time, I
just turned Megan Smith
speak about how it's so urgent
that we bring in everyone.
And so all of these
things are here and real,
and it's really hard.
Part of what "Lean
Out" does is it
describes the shape of
the problem as many of us
experience it.
But it's really just a start.
I'm still figuring out what
the solution looks like.
And that's one reason why
we I'll want to open this up
pretty quickly into a
conversational format,
because I think a lot of
us are trying to figure out
what those solutions look like.
But kind of understanding
the shape of the problem
is a really good start.
So, recruitment-- a company
like Google doing recruitment
doesn't necessarily mean
hiring or promotion.
And this is all
the more true when
it's things like
teaching kindergartners
how to code, right?
Like all that does is increase
the possibility of applicants
that a company like
Google might bring in,
but it doesn't come
with any responsibility
to actually support,
fund, or promote
all of those people who
now know how to code.
It doesn't mean they're
going to get jobs
or they're going to get funded.
So that's one of
my reservations.
Being a qualified woman
does not necessarily
lead to being hired, promoted,
funded, or respected or treated
well once you land
somewhere, which
is part of the hard problem
that we're figuring out now.
Something else I'll
go into, because I'd
like to read a little
bit from "Lean Out,"
is that I love all the
additional opportunities
and resources that
are coming now
with recruitment
efforts for women,
but I just want to
take a lot of care
that we don't say that
women need special programs.
I've never felt that I
needed something special
to be interested in
tech, and I think
that's true for many women
and people of color and LGBTQ.
I'll focus
specifically on women,
but in "Lean Out"
in this preface now,
really we're
talking more broadly
about all
underrepresented groups.
I think it's not that women
need special programs.
We just need respect and to
have-- well, I'll get into it.
To be very clear, women,
LGBTQ, and people of color
are already here, and
we are already awesome.
So if you'll indulge
me, I'm going
to read a little bit from
the chapter that I wrote
and then open this up and
we'll see what you have to say
and what your questions are.
That's good with everyone, yeah?
OK, cool.
My chapter is called "The
Pipeline isn't the Problem."
"The pipeline problem,
a narrative that
states that the reason big
tech companies have poor track
records for hiring
and promoting women
is because there
are too few women
interested in or
skilled in STEM.
The idea that tech has
a pipeline problem, one
that can be solved by teaching
five-year-old girls to code,
infuriates me.
It's awkward to say so.
I need to tread
carefully here, lest I
be accused of bad feminism.
I can see the headline now--
'Lady Boss Against STEM
Education for Girls, Also
Secretly Hates Puppies.'" I
don't hate puppies,
but I'm allergic.
So, you know.
"I am, of course, in favor
of teaching girls to code.
And it is true that
there are more men
than women applying for jobs
and programs in Silicon Valley.
But the reason why we don't
have more women in tech
is not because of a
lack of STEM education.
It's because too
many high profile
and influential individuals
and subcultures within the tech
industry have ignored or
outright mistreated women
applicants and employees.
To be succinct, the
problem isn't women.
It's tech culture.
That's the issue that
needs to be addressed.
The work that I aim to do
here is clarifying the nature
of the women-in-tech
problem to the extent
that we agree
something is wrong.
The women who work in tech
agree that the problem
is harassment, discrimination,
and a generally hostile work
environment.
Many site difficulties
being hired, promoted,
or getting funding.
An overwhelming number of the
highest profile technology
companies have had
a sexual harassment
scandal that has made headlines,
many within the last year.
It is unsurprising
that these companies
have difficulties hiring women.
In 2012, I was told by a
senior manager at YouTube
that I was not
qualified for Google."
Some context here is
that I had actually
been in tech since 1997, and I'd
had a lot of technology jobs.
"I was told, Google
only hires the best."
That's you guys.
Despite spending many days
at YouTube and at Google,
I was never recruited.
I would go there to visit
my housemate, my friends,
or to meet with
business contacts.
I'd even lunch at the
YouTube HQ, Google Cambridge,
and Google Mountain View.
There was a time when I was
quite the Google fan girl.
I would have loved to have
worked on Google+ back when
the product will
still promising."
[LAUGHING]
"I am known for having a
lot of self-confidence.
Claire Cain Miller of
"The New York Times"
described me as having
entrepreneurial brio.
I do not have a
confidence problem.
But I definitely
integrated the idea
that I would not
be hired at Google.
In retrospect, I may
have had opportunities
if I had fought for them.
But Google is espousing the
idea that women are nowhere
to be found.
I was on campus
frequently and would
have been an easy recruit.
Google, and every
other big tech company,
can't ask for much more than
for potential female hires
to walk right onto campus,
as I did frequently
in 2011 and 2012.
I have brilliant
female friends who
have applied for roles at
Google and other tech companies
and have also been rejected.
I am very curious
to understand why."
Then I go on.
"So let's stop saying
that women aren't here
or that they aren't skilled.
Let's instead look at
why we're not seeing,
hiring, promoting, funding,
respecting the women who are.
As [INAUDIBLE] tweeted at the
Lesbians Who Tech conference,
'I believe the best way to hire
women and people of color is
to higher them.' Sometimes I
think it really is that simple.
The best way to hire more
women is to hire them.
We're already here, and
we are already awesome."
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
So I think that's enough
to open things up.
Let's take questions
and take it from there.
Can you hear me?
I see [INAUDIBLE] getting a mic.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was hoping for
a clarification.
You said that
we're already here,
and we're already awesome.
So one of the criticisms
was the big tech
companies aren't hiring women
applicants who are already
there.
Is that because there's
an implicit bias?
Is it because they're not sort
of choosing to hire more women?
So what do you think
the root cause is?
If there's women
who are here who
are awesome who can be hired
and tech companies are at least
saying they want
more women, where
is the gap between the two?
What is the cause of
them not being hired?
ELISSA SHEVINSKY: I
think we're all trying
to understand that right now.
And I give Google
a lot of credit.
It's my belief that many of
the upper management in Google
are also working on this.
So with that in mind,
I think some of it
is not seeing the
potential applicants.
I'll use myself as an example.
I'm never recruited-- ever--
maybe like once every 60 days.
And I'm fairly prominent.
So companies are saying
they can't find women,
but are they actually
really looking?
So I think that's
the first part.
Like women are here
in the ecosystem,
but we're not
necessarily showing up
where you're hoping to find us.
For example, I'm part of
a Female Founders group.
There are a ton of women there.
Many of them would
probably be really
happy to get a job at Google.
Right now I'm pretty busy.
I have this book out.
I have a conference.
I have a company.
But six months ago,
that was not the case,
and anyone could have hired me.
And I begged my
friends to hire me
as my startup was shutting down.
And my friend hired
me, and that was great.
But it goes to show
that we're here
and we're not necessarily
being seen by the companies.
AUDIENCE: I mean, one
thing I'll point out
is that recruiters will often
ask, who do you know, right?
Who can we go and
talk to and recruit?
And if the people that you
know are very much like you,
then that's going to
be a problem, right?
Like there's network effects,
which is one small part.
ELISSA SHEVINSKY: That's
a really important point.
And that's often cited.
When you have organizations
that are led by white men
and many of the
employees are white men
and then they're asked to
go to recruit their friends,
they're going to go and recruit
people from their network.
So we have this problem of, how
do we get outside our network
and find all these
other people who
are going to think differently?
And I think that's
actually very important.
I'm not a social
justice warrior.
That's not the place
I'm coming from.
I mean, I care about that a lot.
But I'm worried
about how we're going
to solve all these
problems without bringing
in everyone's perspectives.
AUDIENCE: So, I'm in
my mid 30s, and I've
been in technology about
as long as you have,
through the back door.
And I read that I'm
entering the big washout
period for women in technology.
And looking around, I actually
don't see many women much older
than me.
And I'm curious-- a few.
You guys are very gracious.
Thank you.
But I really do wonder, it's
not just the pipeline issue.
It's not that the
women are here.
It's also that
women are choosing
to leave technology companies.
And in my own experience, I
think that culture actually
does a lot to do with that.
The higher you get, the
more the dukes come out,
the more aggressive
and assertive,
the more you really can't cry.
What do you think about that
mid-career female technology
path?
ELISSA SHEVINSKY: I think
it's not only for women
but that there's this
fetishization of youth.
Now, I'm a [INAUDIBLE] mentor.
I am very, very excited
that young people are
being given the
opportunities they are,
that they're being
taken seriously,
and I love the work being done
by innovative young people.
But I also love the work
done by older people.
We do a different kind
of work in general.
The people involved with me
and my company are all older
than me.
We're building an
enterprise security company.
We're building stuff that needs
to scale, that cannot fail,
that cannot have
vulnerabilities,
that you can't build
over a hackathon weekend.
And sometimes older
people in our ecosystem
aren't valued as much as I'd
like to see them being valued.
And that's true
for men and women.
But these issues become
exacerbated for women
because we're already
facing so much.
AUDIENCE: Just to
put a stat on that,
I believe I saw something about
the dropout rate for women
after 10 years, and
tech is about 50%.
But agreed since
I'm in that group,
it's wonderful they
resolved the sexism that one
had to deal with,
and now it's, oh,
ageism plus sexism-- awesome.
I have a question just about
the title of your book.
The title "Lean Out" is
invoking obviously a reference
to Sheryl Sandberg's book.
And I was wondering how is your
message directly addressing
her message?
ELISSA SHEVINSKY: Not as
much as you would want.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering.
I didn't hear as
much of it here,
and I was wondering in what
you've talked about so far,
and I was wondering whether
there was more in the book.
ELISSA SHEVINSKY: Right,
well, there is, actually.
And it comes through when you
read the book as a collection.
So I'm very grateful
to Sheryl Sandberg.
I think that she's been
a trailblazer for women
in tech and in business.
It was really impactful
when her book came out
to see someone of her stature
taking on feminism as an issue,
encouraging women to be leaders.
And we needed that.
And that's why this book
has been a bestseller
since it launched.
But three years later,
"Lean In" just isn't enough,
and it doesn't
speak to all of us.
What "Lean Out" does
that I'm so proud of
is it brings together
so many different voices
from so many different people.
And I'm not on the cover.
The book is an
effort to encapsulate
the experiences of as
many people as possible
in the industry and
to speak to what
it's like to be someone who
isn't white and over-educated
and reasonably pretty.
And I'm too close
to that demographic,
which is why there's so many
collaborators in this text.
And it speaks to being
a person of color,
being LGBTQ, being in gaming.
And there's something
really powerful about that.
I think we all see
that, that it's
time not only for more
voices to be heard
but for more approaches, right?
Like one of the chapters in
"Lean Out" talks about not
drinking the Kool-Aid.
And just one approach
really doesn't fit all.
I was just on Twitter, and
Sam Altman was giving advice.
And it was like, man, like this
it works for the 20 people who
you're mentoring right now.
And those of us who aren't
fitting into that mold,
we need to start
doing things our way.
And the book hints
at that and explores
that in different chapters.
I think one example
I like to give
is how it's harder for
women and people of color
to get really
early-stage funding.
It's always hard to get
I have a lot of white
guys coming to me,
and they're like,
Elissa, can you help me?
So the ecosystem is hard on
a lot of people right now,
but it's like almost impossible
for women and people of color.
So Melanie Moore's advice in
the book, and I'm echoing that,
is to build a business
with customers,
try and go around
these obstacles.
If Silicon Valley
isn't working for you,
we need to figure
out another way.
Maybe it means building
a lifestyle business,
but maybe that shouldn't
be stigmatized.
Silicon Valley VC firms are
not giving a return back
to their investors.
Startups are failing.
The default is that VC
firms and startups fail.
So it's time that
we stop stigmatizing
these profitable, stable
lifestyle companies with people
who are actually building
businesses with real customers.
AUDIENCE: There is a very good
op-ed piece in "The New York
Times" today about
the gender gap in pay.
And one of the things
that it points out
is that the UK now requires
large companies to publish
their gender gap figures.
When PricewaterhouseCoopers
in the UK did this,
they discovered that
almost the entire pay
gap was due to lack of
women in higher positions.
And so they studied
it, and they found out
that indeed there was a serious
promotion problem, just backing
up your point.
Now, I know that Google has
internally studied promotions
in the last few years.
It's been a while since I
looked at those figures.
I don't remember what
the conclusion was.
I don't remember that there was
a huge gap in promotion rates,
but I may be totally
misremembering.
Maybe other people do.
So that would be one thing
if somebody would answer.
But two of the
really common reasons
that are now cited
for this problem
basically put the onus on women.
One is that women
take more time off
than men, of course to have
families and so forth and just
in general once
they have families,
are not willing to work
the crazy hours that men
are, because they want to devote
more time to their families.
And as a result of this,
they don't get promoted.
The other thing that
people often say
is that women are simply
not aggressive enough
in pursuing both promotion
and higher salaries.
They don't ask for them.
And when they do ask, they
don't ask for as much as men do.
So I'd be really
interested in your response
to those two things,
which one now
sees just about
everywhere cited as two
of the really main reasons.
ELISSA SHEVINSKY:
Right, so I understand
how people can look at that
data and say, well, it's fair.
But I actually
think that it's BS.
Because you have a system that
was created by men for men.
And now women are coming in.
And the thing is, men are now
saying they want women here,
whether that's because of
political and social pressure
or because they actually
see the value of women
in the workplace.
Nonetheless, we have the
leadership at companies saying,
we want women here
in our companies,
we want to retain them, and
we want to promote them.
So we need to find ways
to do that without placing
all of the onus on women.
And we know that women
negotiate differently than men.
Why is our system
for promotions based
on this setup that makes
sense for men and not
for women when women are
now coming in the workforce
and we're saying that we
want to integrate them
in a meaningful way?
I think that's the lens
that's useful to look at this.
Yes, women aren't
playing the game the way
men are expecting them to.
But if we want women
to be at our companies
and stay and be happy and be
promoted, that's on all of us
to figure out how
we change things.
And that's part of what
"Lean Out" means to me.
"Lean In" was saying,
all right, women,
like this is how you behave
like men to get ahead
and get that seat
in the boardroom.
And that was a step
forward, but now
that men are saying
they want women here,
now it's time to say, how
does the workplace accommodate
women?
How do men start to change their
behaviors to welcome us here?
That's the conversation I
want us to start having.
And it's hard.
In the back.
AUDIENCE: One thing
that you brought up
that took me a
while to internalize
is when you said funding.
Because I have
friends in academia,
and so originally I thought you
were talking academic funding.
But I believe you're talking
about things like VC funding.
Is that correct?
ELISSA SHEVINSKY:
Right, I'm coming
from the startup community.
And I have a bias in my
language towards that.
I'm very interested in academia,
but I don't know much about it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, we just came
from two different worlds,
and now I'm getting it.
And it's interesting because
I wonder to what extent
that feature of the
tech world right now,
the fact that one of the
images of the very, very
successful person in our world
is someone who has come up
with an idea, gone in
front of investors, said,
here's my idea.
Do you believe in my idea?
Do you believe in me
to execute that idea?
And that's the startup founder.
There are many other
fields of business
in which that is not nearly
as prevalent a model.
Many more people in
that field of business
might be someone who came up
through the ranks in a very
established company,
and that's seen
as being one very valid
way of being successful.
I'm curious if the dynamics
of that, you think,
are somewhat holding
tech back compared
to other fields of business,
that feature of the economics
of the business?
ELISSA SHEVINSKY: I think
tech is doing great, actually.
I think that we're seeing
tremendous innovation
in technology.
People like [INAUDIBLE]
critique technology
for not necessarily focusing
on important enough problems.
And I think there's something
to be said for that.
But of all the industries,
you look at technology,
and the pace of innovation
is just incredible.
And I look at my own life and
the quality of my own life
has improved so much
due to technology
just in the last few years,
and much of that technology
has come out of Silicon Valley.
So as much as I'll stand here
and criticize some aspects,
I do think there's
something there
that's working really well.
What I worry about with
funding is how much of that
ends up being about camaraderie
or believing in someone.
And I'll give an example
that I may regret later,
given that this is a live feed,
but I think it's important.
I was fundraising last year with
my co-founder, Pax Dickinson.
And we had between 10% and
20% week over week traction
with the teenage market.
We were able to go into a
school and get any target group
off Snapchat using us instead.
So we had a lot going for us.
But we had problems
as well, some of which
are pretty well known.
What's interesting
is the VC response.
Some of the feedback
I've gotten was
that, Elissa is too confident.
She gave too high a valuation.
The other feedback is, Elissa
is not confident enough.
So there was this kind
of intense scrutiny
around my confidence level.
And I'm not sure
that gendered or not.
That's part of the
problem we deal with.
That's why it's
helpful for us to have
these kinds of conversations,
talk on social media,
discover if there's
a commonality,
if gender is that commonality
in a lot of experiences people
are having.
But I suspect that my gender
may have had something
to do with that.
Why was everyone so focused
on my confidence level?
We had really great traction.
AUDIENCE: So I also
have a question, which
is one thing that I've heard a
lot in the past couple of years
is that part of the problem
with recruiting women who
are already here
and able to code
is that the very small number
of women in the company
is part of the problem,
and it's also part
of the problem for retention.
That is, those who are
already in the company
are more likely to leave because
of the culture in which there
are very few women.
So I wonder what you think about
the interplay between retention
and recruiting and pipeline
and how maybe each one of them
affects the other.
ELISSA SHEVINSKY:
That's interesting.
I've been here a lot
from women involved
in diversity outreach efforts
within their own companies.
And it seems to be
very draining for them.
I don't know
anything about this.
I kind of became like
this accidental feminist.
And like here I am, and
now obviously I'm in it.
But when I started
Glimpse with Pax,
we just hired the
people who we could.
We were grateful that we
could hire anyone at the time.
And we hired a
bunch of white boys,
because that's who we knew
and that's who worked for us,
and we weren't thinking
about it very hard.
And so I actually have never
been in that corporate setting
where someone's asked
me to take this on.
But I think that companies need
to be very aware that women,
feminists, civil rights
activists, they consider
that to be unpaid
emotional work and are not
necessarily happy about it.
I think the companies
look at it as a favor,
like here we are at
this big tech company,
and we're going to care about
the thing you care about,
so here, go do 20
hours worth of work.
I think if the companies made
it like a really important
position in the company
and really well paid,
I think if there was
more benefit and prestige
and tangible reward
attached to doing that work,
then that would help retain the
women who are in the company
and bring in new people.
But we could talk
about this all day.
It's a really,
really hard problem,
and I suspect that those of you
who are actually here at Google
probably have more
insight than I do,
although I'm studying
this pretty hard.
In the back.
AUDIENCE: So I
have two questions,
but I'll stick with one for now.
I'm a proud Harvey Mudd alumni.
ELISSA SHEVINSKY: Harvey Mudd!
AUDIENCE: Yes!
They've done a bunch
of stuff that's
been incredibly successful
in getting women
into computer science
by making small changes.
And I've talked with
them a little bit
about their theories
about why it works,
and there's some
interesting stuff there.
And they've also
done a whole bunch
even more recently to bring in
underrepresented minorities.
And one of the things that
changed the average acceptance
rate from below the overall
Mudd acceptance rate
to higher than that was
just having faculty,
which self-organized
on a mailing list,
call every accepted student
and say, hey, we like you,
and we would like
you to be here.
And that small change
made a big effect,
and now the new student
rate is much improved,
and it makes a big
difference on campus.
Do you have thoughts on
things that tech companies
can actually do that might make
similar substantial changes?
ELISSA SHEVINSKY: I
think that's right.
I have a friend who
did work at Google.
And actually she
still works at Google.
She's been very successful here.
And Facebook tried
to steal her away.
And Sheryl Sandberg herself
called her on the phone
and encouraged her to lean in
and said, we want you here.
I want you here.
And that was very meaningful.
And this friend of mine
ended up staying at Google.
But she's also
deeply wanted here.
And she knows that.
I think there's something
really powerful about knowing
that a place wants you.
I recently joined the Mach37
Cybersecurity Accelerator.
I don't know how
much all of you know
about the infosec industry,
but especially in DC,
it's not only white
and male, it's
white and male and military.
So it's not a place
that I would have
thought is naturally my place.
But I knew that they
really wanted me,
and then when I got
there, it was really nice.
And we were part of the
first class of women,
and there was some learning
for everyone around that.
But I didn't care
that this program was
run by white men,
most of the alumni
and the connections
were white men.
It was like, we're all hackers.
We have that in common,
and they want me.
And I talk about that in the
book, too, in "Lean Out."
And everyone who is here gets
a free copy so you can read it.
When I got into
computer science,
it's because they wanted me.
That was very impactful.
I was getting recruited
left and right.
The computer science department
was really warm and friendly.
Everyone wanted to
teach me how to code.
And I think that has a lot
to do with where I am now
in tech, where I love it
and all of this sexism
just feel so foreign
to me, like it's
this thing that's happened that
I can't even believe happened.
Because when I got
into technology,
that was not my
experience at all.
And I think that that's
a big step for us,
to let people know
that they're wanted.
AUDIENCE: Maybe
one followup thing
is that I think a lot
of people at Google
often feel impostor syndrome.
And I think there's gendered
aspects to that in general,
but I also think there is
this, am I really good enough?
And here I am doing this hiring,
and would I pass this hiring
interview, can lead to
doubt about whether you're
really qualified in general.
And with that, am
I really wanted?
Or would somebody
else be better?
Which I don't think is
necessarily only gendered,
but I think it plays
into the, where else
are you getting signals
about being wanted?
ELISSA SHEVINSKY:
Right, and it's
been talked about very widely,
but it's worth reiterating here
that women will only apply for a
job if they're super qualified,
whereas men will apply if
like-- they'll just apply.
And I'm trying to learn
that lesson myself.
And I should have just applied
to Google+ when I thought that
was like the most
badass thing ever.
And I didn't because I didn't.
Because as confident as
I am, I didn't have it.
So when we do our recruitment
process, we need to know that.
If we actually
really want women,
we need recruit for women.
AUDIENCE: I think there's
also an aspect of,
if there's a culture
of elitism, you
have to actually tell people
at some point, you're OK.
ELISSA SHEVINSKY: Yes.
Yeah, like you're here.
You're one of us,
for better or worse.
And you're not the only one
who's figuring out your job.
Any other questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: This
isn't a question so
much as to respond to
your point about what
small, concrete
actions could be taken.
I just wanted to
share something that I
know my previous company did.
They're called [INAUDIBLE],
and they actually
do pretty well in terms of
hiring women and minorities.
And one thing they do
in the interview process
is, for one, they
always make sure there
are two people interviewing.
And they also treat certain
things like [INAUDIBLE]
when an interviewer
says, I don't think
they're going to fit in, or,
I don't think they're like me,
they immediately throw that
out, because that will just
encourage a company that has a
certain culture to keep hiring
people who are similar to them.
And it's a very natural
human thing to do.
But they explicitly make sure
that as part of the interview
process, they don't
want that to factor in.
AUDIENCE: Just to tie
together these two
comments about the
rate of promotion
at Google, so when
they did the study,
they found that at every
level, as you go up,
the number of women at
that level are halved.
And so when you get to a certain
level, the percentage of women
is very low.
And that's the
case in Cambridge,
as well as elsewhere.
And when they did that
study several years ago,
they noticed that when
women went up for promotion,
they were promoted
at the same rate
as their male
counterparts, but they
were trying to go up for
promotion half as often.
And the sad part about
that was the conclusion
was that women weren't
trying to get promoted.
And there were many of us
who, I think at the time,
were upset about that,
because usually people go up
for promotion when they get
a signal from their boss
that that's going to go through.
And so there are signals
about feeling wanted,
about feeling accepted, that
maybe were not getting through
or simply the managers were
not indicating beforehand,
well, I think you
should try to go up.
ELISSA SHEVINSKY: I think that's
right in that there's just
so many elephants in the room.
There's so much that
we don't talk about.
I was in a conversation
in a closed Facebook group
recently that delved
into some of the concerns
that hiring managers
have about women.
And in this case, some of
those interviewers and hiring
managers had made their concerns
explicit without realizing
they were expressing illegal or
just kind of offensive things,
including trying to suss out
if the women were about to make
babies or interested in
making babies and just all
the presumption that women after
a certain age, that age being I
guess, I don't know, 17, are
going to see at some point
drop their careers and
go and make babies.
And that's very frustrating
for the women who
feel that by showing up to
interview or by showing up
to ask for capital, they're
saying that they're in it.
And that's my feeling,
like if I show up
and I say I'm going
to do it, I want
you to take that at face value.
So I worry about that
with some of these issues
that the hiring
managers may assume--
like there may be both implicit
and explicit bias there.
And also.
If I may-- and hey,
I have the stage,
so I can-- women
will say that they're
leaving for family or for
babies or for all these reasons,
and that's not always why.
And I say this as someone
who has leaned out and left
so many times.
And it's only now that
I'm more self-aware
and that I'm aware of these
issues in the industry
that I can look back and
say, oh, yeah, that time
that I left the country,
like I quit my job
and left the country,
it's because I
felt like I'd run out of
options at my current company.
I didn't understand how I could
improve my career back in 2005.
I was thinking
maybe grad school,
but that felt very amorphous.
And I ended up an
ex-pat, and then I
ended up married and
years of adventures.
And why did that happen?
It happened because
what I really wanted
was to be a vice president
at Everyday Health.
I didn't know how to get there.
I mean, now I do.
I don't plan to leave.
I'm pretty busy.
But that's one reason, right?
And I see heads nodding.
Women don't want to leave,
but they can't stay.
The other reason is the
real elephant in the room,
and it's even harder
to talk about, which
is women end up sometimes
with very intense harassment.
My book describes a woman
who's describing rape at work.
There are things that
people experience sometimes
that are deeply traumatic,
and you can't talk about it.
I think it's really important
to read Katie Levinson's article
on whistleblowing if you can.
Sometimes women
can't talk about what
happened to them
because it's not
going to help them personally
and they're already
struggling to deal with
what's happened to them.
They're not in a position to be
an activist or to be a martyr.
They need to get on with their
lives and figure things out.
And so when we assume that women
are leaving to make babies,
I just don't think that's
the reason why a lot of women
are leaving.
Yes, women leave for
family, but we often
can't talk about why we left.
AUDIENCE: I would
just like to point
that [INAUDIBLE] is supposedly
spending time with his family
right now.
And Lucy made this
wonderful snarky point
right behind me a
second ago that when
men leave to say
they're spending time
with their families,
especially if they have just
led the company through a
giant, multi-year disaster,
we all roll our eyes and we're
like, yeah, sure you are.
But if a woman says
it, for some reason
we believe her, and like,
what the fuck's up with that?
ELISSA SHEVINSKY:
Yeah, women-- it's
just the easy thing to say.
You can't say, I'm
leaving because--
and then fill in the
blank with something that
would be a Gawker headline.
No one wants that
for themselves.
AUDIENCE: As just an
anecdote, I had my babies,
and I made it clear to every
single manager since then
that, no, two is enough.
And at my last company,
I made it explicit,
extraordinarily explicit
in every single review
that I was looking
for leadership.
And my CEO told me that he did
not think of me as a leader.
Please notice the
ex-company part of that.
But it would have been way
easier, so much less conflict,
so much simpler for me to either
dodge, hide, use an excuse,
stay low, hide my head,
just keep working hard
and wait to be noticed.
And I really started to feel
like-- my point was actually
less about sexism than
mid-careerism, where you're
looking for those first jobs
as a manager, as a leader,
as a person in the company other
people look to for answers.
And the people above
you say, I'm sorry,
I just don't think
of you like that.
ELISSA SHEVINSKY: And that
is why I'm a startup founder.
But I would be very
interested in figuring out
and understanding
a way for people
to make that happen
in corporate life.
And if anyone has ideas,
I would love to hear them.
AUDIENCE: I'm not sure if it's
a question or an observation,
but regarding the rates
of promotion at Google,
Google is a little weird
in that in most companies,
a manager says, hey, I think
you could do this other role,
and they promote you,
and then you do it.
And Google kind of looks to
you to have started working
above your level already.
And there could very
well be gendered barriers
to doing that, but they might
be very different from the kind
that block promotion
at other companies.
Maybe it's a reluctance
to work above your level
when you haven't been blessed.
Maybe it's resistance
from other people
to taking your leadership when
you haven't been promoted yet.
Maybe it's lack
of encouragement.
I don't know what it is.
AUDIENCE: That is
really interesting.
I want to speak to that
really briefly, because
in this one particular way,
I'm a very stereotypical woman,
so I can speak to the
like totally girly side.
I've been at Google
for eight years now,
and I've been eventually
through two promotions.
And I am one of those people
who won't apply for the job
unless they have every
single bullet point.
And I also will not
go for the promotion
until I have every
single bullet point.
And for that reason, I think
it's actually kind of nice
that Google lets you
work at that level
before you take the
title, because I would not
go up for the title until I
had actually done those things.
Because I would say, I don't
know if I will try those things
and fail.
So I actually think it's a
very also feminine-style,
friendly way to do it
that Google is doing.
ELISSA SHEVINSKY: Well,
I'm glad to hear that,
and I'm really optimistic about
what women are going to build.
That's part of
the message that I
hope will come through
with "Lean Out,"
is that it's really hard relying
on systems that are already
made, that other people made.
I think that some of
the change that we're
going to see in
Silicon Valley is
going to come from just
creating our own institution
and making new
ways to do things.
And I think it's time for that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
well, just to expand
on that, how much of
the problem is just
a pervasive culture that rewards
individualism and aggression.
For example, when people
in the whole tech industry
talk about the kind of
person they want to hire,
they often use the
term rock star.
I hate that term.
I think it should be
completely banished.
My associations with rock stars
are almost completely negative
and not the kind of
people that succeed
or that you would
want in your company.
Why can't we have a
system that promotes
cooperation, communication?
Those are the kind
of things that I
find most lacking among many
of the males that I work with.
And they're extremely important.
Companies, I think, and groups
that can promote those traits
actually probably are more
successful than groups that
don't.
There's just so many
aspects of this culture
that every day promote the kind
of individualist, aggressive
traits that
stereotypical males have.
ELISSA SHEVINSKY: Let's
take three more questions.
And yes, 100%-- I
think that the best
people on tech teams
in my experience
are the ones who are like glue,
who somehow make everything
go right.
Like yes, there
are those engineers
who are 10 times better
than everyone else.
I've seen that.
But in a team, that's not
always what it's about.
And yeah, 100%, I think we
need to focus on collaboration.
And in my personal experience,
just for me personally,
the worst experiences
I've had at companies
have been with people
whose egos were threatened
and who maybe were
threatened by me
or threatened by someone
else in the organization.
And I'm personally
very interested
in genuine meritocracy,
which is something
that I don't see a lot of.
But I believe personally
that if we found a way
to have less like
egocentric, ego threatened,
incompetent people in teams,
that it would be better
for women, LGBTQ,
people of color.
I know it would
be better for me.
When I come in somewhere as a
strong woman and I'm excited
and I'm ready to
do my part and I'm
being treated like
an expert, there's
that one person who's like,
she's figured out that I
don't know what I'm doing.
Like look, I'm not here to take
you down, but like they get up
in my grill, and that's
that lack of cooperation.
I think the best
people are thinking how
we move the whole team ahead.
AUDIENCE: And switching
gears a little bit,
I was hoping you could expand
a little on your statement
that the pipeline problem
is not the problem.
Because I think
it's hard to deny
that it is a problem, given that
graduating classes of computer
science majors have something
like 20% women and 80% men.
And while I acknowledge
all of the problems
that you are you are pointing to
as definitely genuine problems
in the industry
itself, could you just
expand on that
statement and what
you think we could do
better as opposed to having
special programs for women?
ELISSA SHEVINSKY:
Yeah, for sure.
So part of what
I'm really trying
to show in my chapter
"The Pipeline Problem"
is that we all agree there's a
woman-in-tech problem, or a man
problem, as Claire
Cain Miller put it.
But it's a question
of perspective, right?
The problems for female founders
and for female developers
are different from the problems
faced by hiring managers.
Now, hiring managers
have a pipeline problem.
Hiring managers have a problem
that social justice warriors
are yelling at them
when they don't
have enough women in
their organizations
and they need to
bring in more women,
but that's hard because
the women are not
showing up at the door.
I'm not that worried
about that problem.
If the executives at
Google have trouble
hiring people and meeting their
bottom line, like I'm a CEO,
I'm a venture capitalist.
I'm down.
I understand why they care
about that and I'm sympathetic,
but I think that that's
the problem of executives
in the technology industry
and of shareholders.
And that's not who I'm
worrying about right now.
The people I'm worrying about
are very specific demographics.
I'm worried about the
women, the people of color,
the LGBTQ people who
are already here,
who are already
qualified, and they're
having a nightmare of a time.
And those are the people
I'm worried about.
So I worry about
what happens if we're
going to create more of that.
Like why do we want so
bring in more people
to an environment that
isn't ready for them?
And I worry, OK, so what
if these organizations are
trying to have one token woman?
There are already, say, 10
women for that job right now.
So you're going to
bring in another 30?
OK, so now you have
39 unemployed women.
That's what I'm worrying about.
I'm not saying that there
isn't a problem of having women
in these companies,
but I don't see
how we bring more women
into where we are now.
I think we need to make some
changes and welcome women.
And the way to do that is
to hire and fund and promote
and respect women who are here.
And then we'll go.
We'll be evangelists, right?
Like if I go and I sell my
company for a billion dollars--
or maybe we never sell.
We IPO, or my friends, right?
Maybe my friends go and
they all get fantastic jobs,
and they become VPs
and they get funded.
What are we going to do?
We're going to recruit
women to our companies.
We're going to become angel
investors and fund them.
So that's the path that
I think is interesting.
Like what if we just took
the women who are here
and we empowered them and
we gave them resources
and we made them
really successful?
And we put them on the
covers of magazines.
All right, now
you're organically
going to get people saying,
oh, those are role models.
I kind of relate to them.
So I think that you can solve
the problem organically.
And there's one
more thing that I
think is really interesting
that we don't talk about enough,
which is Steve Jobs,
Mark Zuckerberg, all
of these young white men faced
a certain kind of discrimination
when they got started, too.
They weren't taken seriously.
They did not look like
what people thought
an executive should look like.
Steve Jobs faced a lot of that.
And then they went and
became super successful,
and now we all think that's
what a founder looks like.
That's what an
executive looks like.
He looks like a 19-year-old
Harvard dropout.
So I'm a venture capitalist.
I'm a free market feminist.
I think that if we empower
women and we put them on stage
and we make them successful--
and they're already awesome,
so I don't think that that takes
a lot-- then all of this bias
will go away on its own.
That's what I think.
AUDIENCE: So I have a
somewhat related question.
Why is technology the
place where it's so bad?
And I think there may be a
couple of tied-in things,
like there are a
lot of industries--
you can look at medicine,
you can look at law.
They're very competitive.
The women were excluded,
and then they're now
like there in record numbers.
And there's these graphs
where it's like, oh,
the entrants looked like
this, and then women in CS
sort of dies off.
And a lot of the
problems we talked about,
like we're talking about
these sort of basic-- I
don't want to say basic
human nature things,
but like societal
structural problems
that aren't necessarily
unique to technology.
Why is it that we're
having so much more
of a problem with this
than other industries are?
Or is it just because we're
so visible because technology
is booming right now?
ELISSA SHEVINSKY:
Well, visibility
is certainly one aspect, right?
Because you're seeing
these big IPOs,
and there's so much money in
Silicon Valley, what happens
here is of tremendous interest.
And there's a lot of glamour
and fantasy in the way
that the media portrays
Silicon Valley.
Although you know what
coding actually looks like.
It's not that exciting.
So what are the
reasons why we do
have these cultural problems?
Because I do believe that
technology does have problems
that we're not seeing
in medicine and law.
I have a friend
who was a doctor,
and when she was a doctor, she
was given a lot of respect.
Then she became a
startup founder,
and suddenly people
are questioning her.
When she was a doctor, she
graduated medical school,
so she had that credential,
whereas with startups, it's
become very fashionable
to be the startup founder,
to be a programmer,
and so we don't always
take people at face value.
So that's one aspect.
And then there's no HR, right?
You have these young
companies and young founders.
They're being given millions
of dollars, or in some cases
not so young, right?
You have a company like
Google that's really grown up,
but they're trying to maintain
this youthful culture,
and the HR is different.
I think that's a
big piece of it,
has been intentionally trying
to have agile environments.
And then you look at who
our leaders have been.
If you read Paul
Graham's writings,
he talks about how to
have a successful company.
And he's saying that you need
to have your own culture,
and you need to be able to
kind of swear and be raunchy.
So some of the thought
leaders in Silicon Valley
have, in their own ways,
encouraged an environment
that you don't see that
same kind of encouragement
in medical school.
Yeah, so I'm going to stick
around for about 10 minutes
and sign books.
I'm really very
appreciative for Google
to have this conversation.
I recently gave a talk against
how the FBI and the government
prosecutes hackers,
and I was really
grateful to be able to give
that talk and publicize it.
And I'm still here.
I'm not in jail.
I kind of feel that way about
giving this talk at Google.
Like giving that talk
about law enforcement
reflects the freedom of
speech we have in America,
and giving this talk
here at Google today
reflects what I believe is a
genuine commitment at Google
to make things better.
So please stay in touch with
me if you're interested.
And one more thing--
you'll forgive the plug,
but you're all tech people.
I'm doing a security conference,
so you all are invited.
You can use friend of
Elissa for a discount.
And-- I don't know--
enjoy the book.
Stay in touch.
[APPLAUSE]